SCHEDULED FOR HEARINGS, BUT NOT
DETAINED.
>> Todd: BRING IN THE SHERIFF
FROM TEXAS BORDERING MEXICO.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS LATEST
EXAMPLE OF HUMAN SMUGGLING
ASHLEY STROHMIER JUST DETAILED.
>> IT IS UNBELIEVABLE, NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN MY
LIFE.
THIS IS PROVEN TRUE, IT IS AN
INVASION.
>> Todd: TIKTOK WAS BEING USED
TO RECRUIT DRIVERS TO TAKE
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE BORDER.
HOW MUCH LONGER WILL THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ALLOW CHINA,
WHICH RUNS TIKTOKS, BY THE WAY,
TO DESTROY OUR COUNTRY, ONE, FOR
THE FENTANYL THEY ARE ALLOWING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND NOW FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
>> THEY WILL ALLOW IT, TWO
YEARS, SIX YEARS, HOWEVER LONG
TO GET THEM OUT, THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THIS.
>> Todd: THREE MILLION BORDER
ENCOUNTERS SINCE JOE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE, BORDER APPREHENSIONS
HAVE DOUBLED, TRIPLING THE
NUMBER FROM 2020.
IT IS CLEAR SECRETARY MAYORKAS
IS NOT DOING HIS JOB, DHS
SECRETARY ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
CALLS TO IMPEACH HIM ARE GROWING
LOUDEDER.
WON'T THE NEXT DHS SECRETARY
RUBBER STAMP WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION WANTS, MEANING
THERE WILL NOT BE A CHANGE?
>> THE WAY THINGS ARE GOING,
THERE WON'T BE A CHANGE, PART OF
THE HOMELAND SECURITY JOB IS TO
PROTECT BORDERS, ADMINISTRATION
NEEDS TO LISTEN TO PEOPLE IN THE
FIELD, BORDER PATROL AND ICE
AGENTS, THEY ARE NOT DOING THAT.
>> Todd: WHAT IS JOE BIDEN
DOING?
NOT DOING ANYTHING WITH REGARD
TO BORDERS, OUR BORDERS ARE OPEN
AND HE'S LASHING OUT AFTER THE
COURT STRIKES DOWN DACA.
COMMITTED TO DEFENDING DREAMERS
FROM TAX OFFICIALS IN TEXAS AND
OTHER STATES THIS CHALLENGE TO
DACA IS EXAMPLE OF EXTREME
AGENDA BEING PUSHED BY MAGA
OFFICIALS.
THAT IS HIS FAVORITE WORD
EXTREME, HOW IS IT EXTREME TO
ENFORCE THE LAW?
>> POLICY SHOULD NOT OVERRIDE
LAW, TALKING ABOUT THE DACA
PROGRAM.
WE HAD ONE IN THE COUNTY, WE
PICKED HER UP TWO TIMES FOR
BEING INVOLVED IN NARCOTICS
DISTRIBUTION, SHE WAS PART OF
THE DREAMER PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY, AFTER WE GOT THROUGH
DEALING WITHER HAD, SHE WENT
HOME TO A NEIGHBORING COUNTY AND
NOW IN JAIL FOR MURDER.
WE CAN'T GET RID OF HER, BECAUSE
SHE IS IN THAT DACA CLASS.
>> Todd: WHAT DOES NANCY PELOSI
SAY, GOT ON TWITTER AND SLAMMED
MAGA REPUBLICANS, SHE SAID, MAGA
REPUBLICANS BLOCKED THIS BILL,
WHILE EMBRACING EXTREME AGENDA
OF ANTI-IMMIGRANT CRUELTY.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, THOUGH, THE
NUMBERS WE KEEP GOING OVER THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER, AREN'T
DEMOCRATIC POLICIES THAT
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO MAKE THIS
DEADLY TREK ACROSS THE BORDER
REALLY THE INHUMANITY HERE?
>> THE INHUMANITY IS ALLOWING
THE PEOPLE TO DIE IN THE BRUSH,
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO GET RUN OVER
BY A TRAIN.
WE HAD ONE LAST YEAR, ONE OF MY
DEPUTIES HAD TO INVESTIGATE
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN RUN OVER BY
THE TRAIN.
THAT IS NOT HUMANE.
BEING HUMANE IS SETTING UP A
PROGRAM SO THEY CAN COME IN
LEGALLY IF THEY MEET THE
CRITERIA.
NANCY PELOSI TALKING ABOUT THE
EXTREME REPUBLICANS TRYING TO
DISRUPT FAMILY LIVES, WHAT ABOUT
THE FAMILY LIVES OF UNITED
STATES CITIZENS BEING DISRUPTED?
RANCHERS, PROPERTY OWNERS, WHAT
ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS?
>> Todd: YOU TOOK